>> THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION --
>> ♪ ♪
>> THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WILL
ESTABLISH A CLEAR PRINCIPLE THAT
WILL GOVERNOR ALL DECISIONS
PERTAINING TO IMMIGRATION.
THE TIME IS OVERDO TO DEVELOP A
NEW SCREENING TEST FOR THE
THREATS WE FACE TODAY.
I CALL IT EXTREME VETTING.
>> WILL THIS MEAN THAT PEOPLE
WILL HAVE DELAYS.
WILL FEWER PEOPLE WANT TO COME.
?
WHAT THE STATE DEPARTMENT DOING
WITH THIS DATA?
>> Shannon: OUR PANEL TO TALK
ABOUT IT.
TOM FROM THE WASHINGTON EXAMINER
AND ELIE, GREAT TO YOU HAVE ON
LIGHTNING ROUND FRIDAY.
TOM, DO YOU MAKE OF THESE
CHANGES?
>> THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
TRYING TO ADDRESS AN ISSUE THAT
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION BATTLED
WITH.
PEOPLE FROM ISIS WHO MIGHT COME
TO THE UNITED STATES ON A VISA
WAIVER PROGRAM.
THEY COULD GET THROUGH THE
PROCESS.
THE REAL ISSUE HERE IS THAT THIS
IS TRYING TO STAY IF A BRITISH
CITIZEN WHO WAS PART OF ISIS
CARRIED OUT AN ATTACK IN KANSAS
CITY, WE WOULD TRY TO DEVELOP
MORE.
SOMEONE WHO IS A TERRORIST
PROBABLY WON'T PUT DOWN ON THE
FORM THEY WERE A TERRORIST.
>> Shannon: THESE ARE SOME OF
THE BULLET POINTS.
APPLICANTS HAVE TO TURN OVER
SOCIAL MEDIA HISTORY FROM 5
YEARS.
NOT PASS WORDS BUT HANDLES AND
ACCOUNTS.
EMAIL ADDRESSES AND TELEPHONE
NUMBERS 5 YEARS BACK AND
INTERNATIONAL TRAVEL.
ANY PRIOR IMMIGRATION VIOLATIONS
AND FAMILY CONNECTIONS TO
TERRORISM.
TOM, DO WE THINK WE WILL
DISCLOSE TERROR CONNECTIONS
THROUGH THE FAMILY?
>> THIS IS NOT THAT EXTREME.
IT DOESN'T APPLY TO PEOPLE WHO
ARE NOT APPLYING FOR VISAS.
NO, IF YOU HAVE SOMETHING TO
HIDE, THERE ARE WAYS TO HIDE IT.
THERE ARE SOME CIVIL LIBERTIES
CONCERNS WITH THIS.
BUT IT'S NOT REALLY THAT MUCH --
IT'S NOT TOTALLY DIFFERENT THAN
QUESTIONS ALREADY ASKED.
IT GOES INTO THE REALM OF SOCIAL
MEDIA.